Heys advance is a segment where i take a
less structured and humorous approach to
look at any topic that crosses my mind
relating to the subject of anime and
manga it contains my raw biased opinion
and is for the purpose of creating the
bait and/or discussion show shouldn't be
taken too seriously got that great now
shut up and listen a common term that
gets thrown around that is guaranteed to
spark a discussion in every piece of
medium is this idea of a golden age when
was the golden age what period of time
really defined the point of a medium
where there was the Hisense the up
consistently high quality war coming out
for gaming you have times like the
16-bit era or the mid nineties one
gaming first started to gain notice in
the mainstream for movies you have the
late 70s to mid 80s at the prime of me
Hollywood or even backed in the 1930s
which is arguably the birth of cinema
what about anime anime has been around
for quite a while since its birth at the
end of World War two and has since gone
through many changes and significant
periods that have changed for anime
years but 20 can we say there was an era
where there was great anime after great
anime being churned out one after
another that really defined the
generation well it honestly depends on
what you define as a golden age the
golden age as it sounds is often
regarded as a peak era of a medium which
could have various defining factors but
for most people I would assume it to be
the time where there's not only great
stuff coming out consistently but also
when it enjoyed a surge of popularity or
to put it in simpler terms people's
favorite period in anime ironically
enough I've already talked about this
exact topic on my very first ranch a few
years ago I made a rant entitled new
anime stucks
where I made the argument that in
general anime had been dropping in
quality since the end of my magical
golden age of animate in 2007 and newer
anime just wasn't as good what I saw was
appeared in the early to mid-2000s of
what anime was producing a lot of shows
that I still regard as modern-day
classics fueled by the internet boom
that saw his popularity skyrocketed
never done before
this was my peak of anime this was what
got me into an r8 this was my Golden Age
of anime and at the time of the rants
back in 2011 this had been slowly
replaced by sea of mowie blobs
slice-of-life shows that only really
pandered to the otaku demographic my
Code Geass is death notes and Barca
notes had gone replaced by KO and Madoka
Magica sanjuana got trees so anime could
only be getting worse right the Golden
Age of anime had come to an end right
now listen carefully because this next
sentence is a line I rarely say and I'm
not sure when you guys will hear me say
it again you
I'm sorry guys I was wrong I was wrong
or at least I've come to completely
change my stance to this topic within
the four years since I made that video
hell I am only human after all
what I've come to realize is that the
reason I regarded it as the peak of
anime was honestly because well that's
the era that got me into anime it has my
favorite shows it was my Golden Age of
anime for a lot of the older guys to go
into anime in the mid-90s with the
advent of cyberpunk sensation such as
Akira and ghost in the shell' they
generally regard that era as the Golden
Age of anime why because that was the
time that they discovered anime and
these trends were the things that got
them into the medium it was their Golden
Age of anime but we also have the 80s
with the start of the overly muscly
overly powered shown in fighting genre
is about the Golden Age of anime what
about the late 70s with the age of the
space opera and the started Gundam was
bad the Golden Age of anime but how
about the actual birth of anime in the
1960s well in my opinion none of them
are it really depends on what era
matches up with your taste for most
because here's the thing anime is always
changing every decade or so breeds a new
age where the trends and types of shows
coming out are completely different but
generally anime isn't any better or
worse in any particular time period it's
just different sure there will be strong
years in others but at the end of the
day your golden age will most likely
depend on your taste or the time period
when you go into the medium right now
I've been an anime fan for so long that
I've witnessed the birth of a whole new
generation of fans right under my nose
with the invasion of the my slice of
life trend in the last half decade the
explosion of social media and the
development of high-quality online
streaming platforms there is a whole new
group of fans getting into anime in
totally different ways watching totally
different things I've come to realize
the fact that not everyone in this day
and age would have got into anime the
same way that I did rushing home from
school so I can watch Dragonball Z as a
kid on tsunami being blown away but if
spaghetti western classics such as
Cowboy Bebop outlaw Stein
try gun on Adult Swim remembering when
fansubs were filled with an
overabundance of translator notes and
weeaboo lingo hard-coded into avi
formats because you know what that was
my era of anime the new era has not only
started but have been running for a
while you thought to be for now and you
hear the stories about how Madoka Magica
licked the fire - the anime love how
watching the cute girls on K on gave
them the light break they need in a life
or have the newest wave of fans
discovered attack on Titan on the week
country or simulcast and have never
looked back since so who's to say were
not in a golden age right now sure the
anime coming out is constantly changing
but in a way that's what I love about it
there are still experimental and new
stuff coming out every year and even if
something like hakuna hana wasn't so
well-received in 2013 there have been
experimental successes ping pong the
animation for its quirky lips was one of
the best shows to come out in 2014 and
even though the franchise has been
milked to death by now it's still
boggles my mind how the monogatari
series became such a massive hit in the
first place considering it was so
different it's not only the anime coming
out but the relevant studios and the
people behind them are not the same
there was a time when anything made by
Studio bones was a guaranteed contender
for anime of the year and an absolute
must watch when production i.g seemingly
had infinitely deep pockets when gonzo
churned out show off the show of varying
quality and when gainax made anything
relevant now ever since Kyoto Animation
completely perfected the art of otaku
pandering with the release of K on there
was a complete power shift he's one of
all have shown the board how gorgeous a
TV series could look anyone pictures has
risen to the powerhouse studio that are
making something every season and
sharped has made the act of tilting a
head into a bonafide art form not to
mention we are seeing a trend of the
relevant people behind the biggest shows
of the last era simply breaking off from
the old studios and forming their own
three of which studio trigger studio
width and studio mapper had between them
made some of the most popular shows of
the last two years the entire anime
landscape has changed into something
almost completely different but I guess
that's just part of growing up times
change people change you change and the
only thing you can do is just accept it
and move on but you never forget your
roots and what it was like before
maybe the reason my golden age was the
period I got into anime was because of
the nostalgia effect especially now when
I look back myself at a time when anime
was still a new thing for me I just
remember how exciting it was everything
was still new and fresh I was
discovering a new world through sugar
coated glasses so of course everything
would have been amazing and right now
when I reflect back on that time I still
get the feeling of nostalgia even if it
might have been as great as I remember
it being but that's how I started
goggles work and I doubt that would ever
stop happening in his new age either
in ten years time it'll be this
generation of anime fans looking back at
this time for
back two years like 2011 when Madoka
Magica steins gate Ana Hana and face
zero started airing in the same year and
they'll say you know what that was the
Golden Age of anime we had so many good
shows coming out back then getting so
many new people into anime and right now
anime just isn't the same it's
completely different and you know what
they'll be right because it won't be hey
guys get ok I hope you enjoyed that
branch I know it's been a while since my
last rants but I want to hear your
opinion when was your golden age or was
there even a golden age of animate to
begin with leave a comment I'll even
make a video because I genuinely loved
the discussions that come out these
types of videos even if video responses
are no longer a thing but anyway with
this I've already managed to beat my
productivity from last year so let's
hope it continues with that trend day so
yeah I've been gig up and I'll see you
guys next time
what so for anyone who I met at MCM last
week I had a [ __ ] ton of fun so if you
guys want me to do some other kinds of
meets up in the future just leave your
comments